before you see him soar into action
here's a look back at some of the other
works who may have seen Zachary Levi
star in if you were wondering this is
why the actor playing Shazam looks so
familiar for his first ever film gig
Levi nabbed a supporting role in the TV
movie bigshot confessions of a campus
bookie the film aired on FX in March of
2002 and although the movie was a dud it
was a great opportunity for Levi to add
a film credit to his acting resume prior
to Big Shot he had only performed in
theater productions with bigshot Levi
was able to get his feet wet in
Hollywood which potentially acted as a
springboard for his careers next big
achievement ABC's less-than-perfect was
a moderately successful workplace sitcom
they debuted in 2002 and ran through
2006 the show followed Sara Rue's Claud
Casey an employee at a television
network other big names in the cast
included Sherri Shepherd and Andy Dick
who played Claude's coworkers
however it was Levi who truly made a
name for himself as Kip Steadman
Claude's elitist frenemy and primary
rival he appeared in all 81 episodes of
the series we're gonna pretend like you
guys didn't do this on purpose we need
to give a shot playing Kip
Levi started to see his life change in a
2003 interview with relevant magazine
the then 22 year old opened up about his
newfound fame it's weird to me it hasn't
all completely sunk in yet but at the
same time I hope it never does I hope
there's always at least the small part
of me that's always surprised always
taken aback always childlike or innocent
in the whole process considering that in
Shazam he played a fourteen-year-old in
an adult's body Levi's apparently got
his wish
2006 is Big Momma's House 2 starred
Martin Lawrence reprising his role of
FBI agent Malcolm Turner and his
undercover alter-ego Big Momma although
its premise is very similar to the first
film the sequel does inject a few new
faces to its story one of those new
additions is Zachary Levi who plays an
FBI agent although Big Momma's House 2
failed to live up to its predecessor in
terms of both revenue and reviews it was
actually a huge milestone for Levi's
career marking the first time his
presence would grace the big screen in
theaters you can safely assume that
being on the set of a
film with a production budget of 40
million dollars was at least slightly
different from Levi's sitcom experience
in his breakthrough role on NBC's cult
favorite TV series Chuck Levi played
chuck Bartowski computer geek turned
secret agent the show perfectly
showcased Levi's full arsenal of acting
chops from humorously innocent to
surprisingly badass his chemistry with
Yvonne Strahovski who played Chuck CIA
handler Sarah Walker also proved that he
could convincingly maintain a love
interest on-screen chuck was a major
part of Levi's life and isn't a role
he'll soon forget speaking with
Entertainment Weekly Levi didn't hide
his desire to make a Chuck full-length
feature film I'd love to do it as far as
I know I'm the only person who's
affiliated with the show that's been
trying to make it happen on some level
I've had meetings with various people
there's just so many moving parts
if Levi's career continues to blossom
don't be surprised to see Chuck the
movie eventually hit theaters after the
first season of Chuck Levi starred in
the road trip comedy wieners in the film
Levi's Kenan Thompson and Fran Kranz
played three friends who embark on a
cross-country mission to hunt down a
talk-show host who's wronged one of them
oh and they drive a hot dog shaped
vehicle to get there obviously
unsurprisingly weiners failed to impress
audiences and was possibly a low point
for Levi's budding career however he had
to know that the movie wasn't exactly
going to be up for any awards from the
start
a hot dog car was probably the first of
several clues 2008 shades of Ray is
difficult to assign a specific genre
with layers of comedy drama and romance
it's sort of a cinematic hodgepodge
the indie film tells the story of Ray
whose parents are of different ethnic
backgrounds and his quest to find the
right woman in the movie Levi starred in
the title role is Ray marking his first
film appearance as the main protagonist
all those shades of Ray wasn't a
box-office hit it did well on the
festival circuit winning various awards
sure it's cool to be able to say you
starred in projects alongside Hollywood
legends like Clint Eastwood Tom Hanks or
Meryl Streep but only a very select few
have the super cool privilege of saying
they've start along side
Alvin and the Chipmunks in 2009's Alvin
and the Chipmunks the Squeakquel Levi
play Toby the video game obsessed cousin
of Jason Lee's chipmunk daddy Dave the
kids movie was a major box-office hit
raking in over four hundred and forty
three million dollars worldwide and
becoming the ninth top grossing movie of
the year
good job Levi and rocketjump studios
webseries video game high school video
gaming has become the most popular sport
in the future and vgh is an organization
that teaches a wide curriculum of
various gaming genres the series has
built up a cult following since it
kicked off in 2012 although he appeared
only in three episodes Levi's time on
vGHS left a lasting impression his Texas
drawl and deadpan attitude makes the
introduction of his first person shooter
course arguably one of the best scenes
in the show's first season hello
students and welcome to fps
[Music]
Zachary Levi made comic book movie
headlines in 2012 when it was announced
that he would replace Josh Dallas a
spandrel and Thor the dark world
although it was a minor role in a film
that already had a very crowded cast
most fans felt as though Levi was a
great replacement for the part and his
dry bravado worked well with the
Asgardian swordsman
although Levi's Fandral had a brief and
fatal cameo in Thor Ragnarok he had
apparently already reached his wits end
with Marvel as he told cinema blend he
was actually hoping for his character to
be killed off because Marvel had failed
to develop any of the Warriors 3 and he
was apparently grateful that Cate
Blanchett's hella finished the job in
Ragnarok in the second season of
Amazon's golden globe-winning series the
marvelous mrs. Mazal Rachel Brosnahan
snoo Lee divorced midge Mazal vacations
with her family to the Catskills in
upstate New York
it's here that midge is set up with
dreamy doctor benjamin edinburgh played
with memorable swagger by zachary levi
midge and benjamin have a rocky start
but eventually their undeniable
chemistry gets the best of both of them
in an interview of The Hollywood
Reporter Levi admitted that although
he'd see
the series is pilot he actually didn't
know that the show was picked up before
he signed on then I got an offer to join
so my first bit of homework who was
binging the first season all and
essentially a day and I immediately
wanted to be a part of this it's so well
executed on every level from the top
down and to get to share screen time
with Rachel Brosnahan in that role
that's an offer you can't refuse
people think if they buy me things I'll
work harder to keep in the line are they
right yes check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]